[Music]
since december 1989
maggie marge lisa homer and bart simpson
have been making families all over the
world laugh
the simpsons always has its finger on
the pulse of the time and regularly
questions and parody social events and
changes
however creator matt groening himself
probably never thought that he would
predict so many occurrences as a result
sometimes it took only a few months
until prediction turned into reality
but in other cases the prophecies came
into effect many years later
in this video we have once again
summarized some of the funniest
and scariest predictions
in the 1995 episode sweet seamer
skinner's
badass song bart takes his dog santa's
little helper to school
ladder is suddenly attracted by the
delicious smell coming from the school
kitchen
here you can see the cafeteria chef
doris freeman preparing the meal for the
students
on the barrel containing the meat of the
words assorted horse parts
what was thought of an obnoxious joke at
the time became reality 19 years later
with the appearance of the horsemeat
scandal
in 2013 food products declared as beef
products were found to contain up to 100
horse meat in various european countries
in the course of the investigations
unidentified portions of other types of
meat such as pork and drugs such as
phallobudazone were also detected to
some extent
particularly a factor were frozen foods
and sauces with minced meat such as
lasagna bolognese and other related
products
but this was not the last scandal
surrounding food products which the
simpsons predicted
in a 1995 episode the teachers went to
the barricades because princess skinner
was cutting corners
that's also with the preparation of the
meals into which he had
old sport mats processed and as in the
previous example
the real scandal followed 19 years later
when the fast food franchise subway
admitted to mixing its bread with azole
carboxamide
indeed this chemical substance is also
found in yoga mats
subway said there was no cause for
concern but stopped using the chemical
from then on
well then bon appetit
the following prediction probably
belongs more to the genre tragedy
in the 1993 episode springfield or how i
learned to stop worrying and love
legalized gambling
two magicians perform in springfield
they visually resemble the magician duo
siegfried and roy in the episode the
magicians are attacked by their white
tiger during a show
exactly the same thing happened 10 years
later to the exceptional magician roy
during a performance with his tiger
monticor
according to the magicians roy suffered
a stroke on stage which prompted the
feline predator to simply come to his
rescue whether that was really the
reason
no one knows to this day nevertheless
roy suffered from lasting damage and
hemiplegia until his death in early may
2020
even in the days of the cold war how
springfield oracle succeeded in making a
prediction that would turn out to be
true 27 years later
in russia in the episode itchy and
scratchy and march
a replica of the statue of
michelangelo's david is brought to
springfield the nudity however
outrages some citizens and their demands
to cover it up precisely the same
happened in 2016 when a replica was also
placed in the beautiful city of saint
petersburg
causing the local residents to become
upset and go to the barricades
but as is well known there's no
accounting for taste
matt groening and his team didn't break
the outcome of the 2017 super bowl but
they did foresee dan's performance in
the 2012 episode called
lisa goes gaga lady gaga comes to
springfield for a concert and her stage
performance is spectacular as always
at the end attached to tightrope she
flies across the stage in a metallic
outfit and there are sparks coming out
of her top
entirely exaggerated certainly not after
all
not only the performance but also the
bodysuit at the super bowl performance
five years later
was very reminiscent of the one in the
episode okay
the sparks might be missing but
otherwise the similarity is astounding
warning the following prediction
contains spoilers for the final season
of game of thrones so if you haven't
seen it yet
you should fast forward now many of you
will surely remember the fifth episode
of this season
in the bells queen daenerys was so upset
that she burned down half of king's
landing with her dragon named drogon
inheriting her father's title
as the mad queen what very few noticed
at the time is that in the 2017 simpsons
episode the surfsons almost exactly the
same scene took place
this is because in the episode which is
based on game of thrones a
town is also burned down by a dragon
whether this was another surprising
masterstroke by the simpsons or whether
the game of thrones creators were even
inspired by the animated series
remains a mystery the episode also has
other easter eggs in store for fans the
three-eyed raven is alluded to there are
white walkers and those who watch the
episode in english may
have noticed that marge's brother was
dubbed by none other than jaime
lannister actor
nikolai coster-walder and that he also
has feelings for his twin sister
simulation games have increasingly taken
over computers and smartphones in the
last decade
be sports train track or goat simulator
they come in all types today
on facebook in 2009 the game farmville
conquered the hearts of million users
old and young sat at the computer after
work and school and built their own farm
the simpsons though came up with the
idea 12 years earlier in the episode
bart carney from season 9 you were able
to see a similar game admittedly at the
time it was still called the yardwork
simulator but
working on a farm also has a lot to do
with gardening
so perhaps the zynga development team
borrowed a few things from it
as we found out in our latest simpsons
video our yellow friends are very good
at predicting things around science
on that occasion it was the discovery of
the higgs boson but they also seem to
have a good news when it comes to nobel
prize winners
in elementary school music from 2010
lisa martin
and milhouse bet on who will win the
nobel prize milhouse bets on bangtar
homstrom in the category of economic
sciences
anyone who watched the series at the
time probably wouldn't have expected
that to become reality six years later
homstrom wins the 2016 prize for his new
theoretical models in social contract
theory
so now we can also include milhouse
among the nostradamuses
the winter sport of curling tends to be
made fun of and dismissed as canadian
and many american series
since their admission to the winter
olympics the us has only made it on the
podium
twice as curling is otherwise very much
dominated by the swedish swiss and
canadians one reason why the simpsons
creators thought to change that for once
in the 2010 episode
boy meets curl homer and marge went to
the winter olympics and won brilliantly
in the final against sweden thus
securing the gold medal for the united
states
all the more spectacular that this event
was to come true eight years later
at the pyongyang games not only was the
color of the metal accurately predicted
but also the opponent
and the result coincided with the one
from the episode
another prediction that hardly anyone
noticed in 2018
in addition to the men's and women's
tournament a mixed doubles tournament
was
also on the program for the first time
so a team consisting of men and women
just like in the 2010 episode
many people dream of their star as beat
actors or musicians responding to the
fan mail at some point
in their lives mother march also
cherishes the stream because she's a
passionate beatles fan
in high school she sent her childhood
crush wrinkles saw a self-painted
picture of him
in the mail 20 years later he opened the
letter and answered her immediately
you don't think it's possible to get an
answer to a beatles fan mail two decades
later
think again in 2013 band colleague paul
mccartney wrote two beatles fans from
essex a belated reply
believe it or not they had sent him fan
mail 50 years ago
here too the simpsons made a good
prediction yet
again however
not all predictions that can be found on
the internet are correct some have been
edited to fit the context take for
example the photo of donald trump with
the saudi arabian king salman bin
abdulaziz and egyptian president abdel
fattah
according to youtube videos and other
sources this was supposedly taken as
early as 2002 15 years before the actual
photo
however it was simply cropped in reality
the image was inserted into the trailer
for the 20th season of the simpsons on
may 26 2017.
it can be seen between seconds five and
six also surrounding the current global
pandemic there are already some theories
circulating
according to some videos and websites
our yellow family is said to have
predicted this catastrophe
however the videos are a compilation of
the episode's marching chains
from the fourth season and the full
monty from the 22nd
which could then be interpreted as a
conspiracy
[Music]
as for 2021 the simpsons has already
made some predictions in the halloween
episode of october 31st
2020 homer forgot to vote during the
presidential election and
once again causes an apocalypse instead
of voting he falls asleep in his hammock
and merely dreams of going to a polling
station
at the end of the day he still thinks it
can't possibly be that bad but when he
wakes up the episode jumps to january
20th 2021
the day of the inauguration of the new
american president homer
sits armed on the roof of his house as
the world ends and even the four
horsemen of the apocalypse fly in the
sky
holding up flags that read treehouse of
horror 31
pestilence famine and war fortunately we
all know that our yellow friends were
wrong on this one and that the world
didn't end on the day of joe biden's
inauguration
let's hope it remains that way and once
again we're through with another episode
hopefully there are some crazy
predictions in this video as well that
got you excited
if you liked the video let us know with
a thumbs up if you get any ideas for a
topic of your own feel free to post it
in the comments below and we might make
an episode out of it
[Music]
you